Americans mostly dislike politicians
congressional approval ratings are on
the floor all the time and once again
Bernie Sanders is America's most popular
and well-liked senator there's a new
morning consult poll with more than
140,000 interviews of registered voters
nationwide and as you can see Bernie
Sanders at the top of all senators with
the highest approval rating seventy-five
percent followed by Brian Schatz at 69%
mazie Hirono at 67% John Hoeven the lone
Republican in the top five at 66% and
Patrick Leahy from Vermont at 66% you
don't get to 75 percent approval with
just Democrats and who are the least
popular senators according to the new
morning console poll at the top of the
list is our buddy
Mitch McConnell a Republican 48 percent
disapproval followed by John McCain Jeff
Flake Democrats John tester and Robert
Menendez what's the big takeaway here
not that Bernie Sanders should
necessarily be the nominee for the
Democrats in 2020 I think it's too early
to even talk about that but the takeaway
relates to a similarly a similar but a
sort of corollary story which is that
many democratic known or donors are
talking a lot about California senator
Camilla Harris for 2020 and we've
learned that money has started to really
pour in for her including at a Hamptons
fundraiser over the weekend one
fundraiser in the room said quote she's
running for president take it to the
bank she's absolutely going to run okay
I've been upfront that there are real
questions about Bernie Sanders for 2020
not the least of which is that he will
be 79 years old on inauguration day in
2021 I'm not being ageist it's more a
question of whether the Democratic Party
wants to run an even older white dude
against incumbent older white dude
Donald Trump but here's the real problem
Democratic donors need to be talking
about how to win in 2018 how to use
their money to that end you need the
House and Senate or at least one of them
to even have a chance
stopping the insanity that's going on
and donors are giving money to Kamala
Harris for some imaginary run against
Donald Trump three years from now
without even having a clue what's going
to be going on politically at the time
anytime you hear pat about donors being
excited about someone three years before
an election you should be worried that's
how we got into this mess in the first
place but especially when there's so
much else to focus on
including 2018 Democrat democratic
donors are gathering in the Hamptons to
give Kamel a harris money for 2020 what
the hell is going on and you take a look
at where Camilla Harris ranks on that
list it's smack dab in the middle she's
at 51% and the other names that they
float are often cory booker or Tim Kaine
they're also right in the middle there
wouldn't it make sense to just go with
the most popular progressive candidates
what does the top of that list without
making the case that they should go with
Bernie I think that there is a case to
be made that it should at least be
someone who is more well-liked and when
we look at just the disaster of the DNC
in 2016 when I read donors love Kamla
Harris and they're getting her money and
she's running for president you've got
some serious problems Democrats Inc
corporate Dems call them what you want
this is a disaster and they need to
focus on 28 to 18 starting like six
months ago
not starting today not starting tomorrow
but starting six months ago send me your
thoughts and I'm missing something here
I'm on twitter at D Pakman the show is
on Twitter at David Pakman show today's
program sponsored in part by tag adapt
the hosting specialists whether you need
dedicated server solutions virtual
private servers cloud server options
custom server solutions colocation
services whatever you need for your
business or project tag a DAB and their
expert hosting specialists and support
will set you up with what works for your
business or project and their hosting
services support a really wide range of
customers and businesses around the
world including bloggers tech startups
financial traders gamers web developers
and more you can use
TDPS 20 to get a 20 british pound credit
towards cloud server options at signup
tag adapt calm /td PS with that you can
try out their services and save 20
british pounds about 23 24 US dollars
you use the code TDPS 20 at sign up da
ga da be calm /t dps check it out